what up mother lovers oh you win trout
that was nice I didn't have to thank
lead-in is we're back resident welcome
back to resident Kenny knee-high episode
3 of Resident Evil 0 what an episode
last week Mary I'm not a dig that was I
was an interesting episode a lot of
people liked it I I really went through
the wringer last week and I [ __ ] up no
just kidding
so as I'm upset about it but I I don't
want to like dwell on it yeah if you're
new to the show
we've been playing through every single
resident evil' got through all the
numbered ones except for this because
it's technically zero is a number
depending on who you ask I don't know I
think it's a conspiracy we've been
working on this all week you ready three
two one and go
yeah go and go and go and left and right
in that and in twelve twelve twelve
twelve total - I think Madonna Madonna
McDuck people assume you're only like
this on camera I'm here to tell
everybody watching this is how she is
like on the weekends I've never I can't
believe that I can move him with the
stereos I could have saved their lives
as always if I knew once again I was an
amazing host and forgot her amazing
guide and forgot to tell you we are we
just got off the train which exploded on
our second try yeah okay got them in
there Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid
costumes okay
I gots a lot of tips from last episode
thank you so much to everybody for as
always for yeah the tips are good I do
not remember some of these games oh
sorry okay so when we think we're in a
mansion now
oh so people were pointing out a tip
that might be helpful I'm gonna find
I'll find the names of these people I
mean there's the regulars like Ava
Cassandra Nathan Shepherd and
xavier roy herrera i'm sorry if i
butchered that uh bullies
let's get those great episode you played
me like a violin screaming my lung out
lungs out as the timer turn red and then
p romantic
i can't believe i like died
so this lobby right here is much like
the lobby the entrance hall the foyer a
if you will of the original have that
vibe to it
so people are saying because you'll come
back here often it's like the
intersection this is a good place to
like hole to drop yeah alright so let me
ask you this then i think I came from
and I don't honestly remember but did I
come from here where did I come from
I believe that mean I believe that main
door because it's locked now yeah but
yeah I think it just brought you in here
after that do you think it'll open back
up because I have the the shot thing is
still in there as well as some other
items some health items I'm assuming
there's a puzzle he you can raise those
swords to get back there so it was carol
was new ski I was saying yeah helpful
tip regarding this room this is a good
spot to leave stuff okay that's a good
thing that you said that because I was
gonna pick up these treat this really a
big item box not as this person said
okay Liam Smith thinks I'm wrong about
Ferrari 3 a few people said that wrong
in what regard remember I said it can't
be your favorite Resident Evil game yeah
I do really saying that no I like it
it's a I wish more games use the Nemesis
system alright I'm gonna go through this
door while you keep talking over there
actually cool I'm sure this is kind of a
widely known anecdote but Bioshock 2
before there were multiple Big Sisters
it was gonna be one big sister that
hunted you a lot oh my god yeah oh yeah
so as you saw from her dance earlier
meri and I both figured out that you
could use the right analog stick and you
and he is using up ammo or she is
whoever you're not you is using ammo and
you could turn that off in the inventory
menu I can yeah attack
you know another thing i can do that i
just realized is I can leave them in
that main area cuz that's they're not
gonna have bad guys in there so I could
just go off on my own
that's good logic I mean I don't know
for a fact the right now I could deal
with them yeah
I'm eating a KitKat and you just say at
a mo it's like melty it's become a
staple of Knable for you to eat during
this I mean I eat too
I know you didn't like to eat I like to
eat I like to hear people eating
you can't your phone out cats are the
silent treat that's so untrue they're so
crunchy not some bullies yeah so
actually we might as well do that just
to see for future reference could you
pause so we can see that pause what we
want to bring up that I want to see okay
so we're at AK is highlighted you can on
the highlight that so he won't auto
attack oh that's cool all right let me
see how do I go over to him no Oh Ellen
well how do I change it I'll click on
partner press X Oh got it
X I think you're on a know how are you
oh yeah you are okay so now idle there
you go
oh so you have to just highlight idle do
not use a quick weapon yeah or
alternatively if you still wanted to
help you can give him the knife although
that he won't really do much okay no he
would defend himself or look to your
point you could leave them in the
entrance I don't I'm going to leave him
for a little bit
sound okay to you mmm-hmm are you doing
like worrying about him we haven't done
much yet so mom I'm gonna oh [ __ ] okay I
promised before the end of today I will
play that intro video I promise
we didn't watch the intro video and I
and I said like Oh episode I'm like okay
I'll watch it tonight I promise when
there are when we reach like an hour I
are like you know you have plans at 6:00
when we eat when we reach an hour-ish
the normal episode time I will go back
and we will restart the game on a
separate save files we can watch that I
left him in the wrong room we'll provide
context to what you're doing in fact we
could go watch it no I'll do it at the
end I'm really sorry I know people I've
been
promising that Michael P I will get to
it I'm so sorry oh my god you're so good
what's your favorite candy silent kinds
that don't make noise when people chew
them so that is no good candy I really
like the sour patch watermelon chewy
ones I know mmm
lemon heads are really good I saw it did
you not want me to be the specific no I
just um I don't even like learn a lot
about it I used to okay here's an
interesting tidbit I drink and or like I
eat relatively healthy now at my at my
age now but when I was young I drank a
ton of soda I don't drink so anymore I
just don't like it and a ton of candy so
I know candy fire um when I was growing
up we never got soda I wasn't yeah well
we were only allowed on Fridays so
that's why I wanted more of it oh wow
yeah I wasn't allowed almost any soda
ever I think the only thing that we
would have sometimes is like you know
like poop like not maybe not kool-aid
but like a kool-aid equivalent yeah this
looks dangerous rounds go who's there
you have to say something if your dad
your husband say something Marco it's
like if you're a cop uh that's gonna
hurt me is there a valve you could turn
off right now all right that can you
open that thing to left of you no um
nothing happens when I hit X I'm so sure
that's gonna hurt me it might just repel
you but yeah I think you're right can I
can I crawl shoot it shoot the steam
[Music]
well there's a safety safe spot I don't
know that's you're looking at Billy on
the map oh I am how do I look at me
you're up there you're blue I wasn't red
oh I got confused myself no let's do it
Oh what if I hurt you
um let's find out you're fine I'm fine
okay so I can come back here eventually
but not right now
not till I reduce the scene it's weird
they didn't tell me how I keep seeing
your reflection thinking that's a zombie
oh I know it's what he does oh yeah he's
not an umbrella dude get down convinced
I'm ready for you you man
hichy tasty get on the ground man
oh that was the same Carroll was new ski
that was the same guy who gave us the
tip about the item box was also telling
us about the idol thank you so that's
very nice to know ok so there's a lot a
ladder here that goddamn camera angle
look at this corners that's not noise
what is that I guess I probably have to
write and I'll just have to go back to
the main area when I get full of junk
look at this giant portrait of a baby I
hate it ok ok this all looks good you
can make em all tops that fuel ok and
there's a shoddy here um ok well here
let me ask you this I don't even have
enough room for any of it should I like
take the statue and like bring it back
to the main room I could also get rid of
these small tubes sure and like bring
them back later
is that worth doing yeah ok wait that's
a shotgun leaning up right there yeah -
spits - spaces yeah so I have to get rid
of these items when they change the
camera angle like that I accidentally go
the wrong way sometimes it was because
of that that they originally had tank
controls how the time turn tables have
turned so I'm just gonna put these
things back in the main room so that I
have a couple more items slots because
they might be used I don't like that guy
did you come through here yeah you were
talking wait hold okay Wow hold on I can
go back some of the architecture in that
room was a bit questionable okay hold on
to it throw these items in this room I'm
gonna leave
what up Billy
what's going on hey I just masturbated
all right look very like there's just no
need you know he would that I do I think
that's why it's stressful oh man it's
like that you're out all right okay okay
well I would love to be done with the
sexual stuff
look it yeah okay it's gonna be hard to
explain yeah those look like what is
this yeah that's an upside-down peepee
with a those are like testes it looks
like with a little bit of a am I just
seeing that or yeah they're like tiny
flower sacks but then what's the one
that's upside down in the middle yeah
it's it's an Ballon community that's
yeah that's like a straight up those are
phallic you know why it's funny I was
thinking the other I was thinking it was
like I think there was a little Georgie
O'Keefe to me the middle one
I don't know what the lowing lower hangy
part is fallopian tubes all right let's
move on
I think we've exhausted that I think
we've really learned a lot maybe that's
just a different way that we perceive
the world
yin and yang kind of thing yeah I think
you just see dicks everywhere something
Freudian to unpack there maybe
wait did you hear that is very heating
Mike and Mary Funko pops I thought I
heard like a breathing maybe it was me
yeah so someone said small piece of
advice to save a lot of time later on
take the hookshot with you is it too
late it's too late well I mean maybe not
but like I can't get in there now oh
[ __ ] there's a bunch of dudes here oh
come on that's scary I didn't get [ __ ] I
was so sure I was gonna push him away
I'm actually not sure what to do
there's too many there's too many
there's too many I'm gonna get picked
and killed once you push him now dodge
runs running I can't dodge both of these
yeah I can eat this I feel bad but Yahoo
as well see that or I start the [ __ ]
thing over that's really annoying cuz I
like Paris I can't see them but I know
they're there so I'm just gonna keep
shooting
that's so unfortunate because a light
way to say that balls why is it
unfortunate cuz I I was loading the gun
I was totally gonna move backwards [ __ ]
scorpions are arachnids by the way
people point that out I was wondering if
there were insects or something else
it's good to know
and that was a scorpion that occurred I
was wrong on several accounts god bless
it I just got so hurt in that section
so what's going on in here yeah what is
this room um it looks like a school
classroom and I'm right training
facility will raise the new generation
of model employees for umbrella Corp
strictest and rigorous training
standards the facility will without
regard for gender race or creed produce
only the best candidates to be the
future global leaders we look forward to
the development discipline obedience
unity discipline and obedience are very
similar job you don't go these three
words are basic principles keep all
these words in mind all the time
devote yourselves to training James
Marcus director umbrella core that's
that dude that uh Wesker and Spencer no
I don't like this area at all okay I
don't
I was shotgun shells over here in a
typewriter I don't have any pucks with
me did you want to save what you've done
so far
shut up it's [ __ ] rude all right I'll
leave this for the dude then did you go
back for a shotgun yet no I didn't I got
distracted and went up the [ __ ]
stairs and then got like eaten alive
dumb idiot I could take it and then get
the shotgun I could do that yeah I'll
just take it and I'll leave the pucks
there because maybe I'll want to save
here one day very weird room it looks
really old but then there's computers in
the tables the desks this area is really
creepy
you don't like anything a lot of people
in all these they're all it's like none
of these people are happy I forget I
came from here so I haven't been in here
and there's another door over there so
I'll go in here first I'm going pretty
deep down the rabbit hole here mm-hmm
I'm okay right now but I think I need to
be careful that I hear it see that naked
baby behind you I see I see it's the
same thing okay so there's a big corner
here so I can't see it unless I go out
that corner so and I'm running out of
bullets so what should I do I'm gonna
reset I'm curious if like this game is
better my burn Code Veronica we were
being way too conservative I think this
you need to be in terms of ammo so look
you didn't tell me that
well I mean you haven't done anything
that I would like say was like I'm just
like who said that is this the kind of
one from like memory I'm not I'm jumpy
today I need the shotgun I think for
those they're too close and I don't want
to take any more hits don't you've
handgun yeah but only a 14 and they're
really close you see that corner yeah I
think I need a shotgun oh you could
check that other door before you go back
all right
I'm like looking at my controller I'm so
sure I was pointing the other way we
stopped ranking the doors we did the
first game and haven't gone back to it
Oh like best door yes it does
okay when good and evil are brought into
balance a new path will be opened before
yeah I have a nitpick aren't they
already in balance based on those scales
yes but there's no good or evil
wait is this just nothing it's just the
home area am i bad yes that's good to
know though is it yeah
where's Billy there he is why you had a
breath why you sweating time in there
Ken evil fiction Billy's just furiously
getting after it when we're gone
stop there's no evidence to support that
ah maybe not to you I can spot the signs
though I do that every day work no I
don't do that I spot the signs at work
is what I meant to say man I'm like I
think you forgot that your reflection of
that window keeps throwing me off you
know it scares me but switch the Billy
and go exploring I will I just wanted
that shotgun and I went the other way
because I keep doing this thing where I
like alright it's faucet it's dry what
are they what about the internet
journalist look like pac-man's this
urinal it's dry there's cocaine in here
okay that's piss
okay those look like very hungry
Pacman's Pakman they are hungry hungry
for piss okay yeah take a dump in the
urinal once there's definitely a [ __ ]
dude in here he's in here
I'm trying to [ __ ]
[Music]
okay with a dream that size down the
center of the floor why do I even need
toilets all right for human decency for
human decency
that's when you need them on top I think
what is it I don't know do you follow me
it's a brilliant [ __ ] pun no so I'm
pissing
run geez what was that you look like a
regenerator from re4 do you think he'll
stay in there like he's not in danger or
is this a safe area can you look that up
no I'd rather find out the funny way go
kill him
bring molotovs no I don't want to go
there's first of all you just told me I
need more conservative my ammo second of
all there's no need for me to to have it
okay if I already got all the items out
of that area yeah there's no reason to
go back there if that's what you mean
if you don't if you got everything go
back this is the worst you've ever
assisted me I don't know they don't know
times I hold on I take great umbrage
with what you just said I remember we
used to have conversation about whether
I'm guiding you too much I think I used
to guide you too much maybe there's a
middle ground between what I'm doing now
and what I used to do I barely scraped
by
I got a derating on like every game oh
wow hold on a second that's being very
generous you got like an F you got an e
on the last game doesn't even exist that
grade is not real that's before s that's
good but it's not as good as D what you
just said but it's better than F no
argument there
I don't have to even like explain listen
to this well that's a different shotgun
that's like a shotgun shotgun his was a
hunting rifle do you think it's better
hopefully would you say it's better or
worse better
it's got seven in it yeah all right
let's go into that area with those
zombies and let's shoot them they're
dead
I have not yet been in a situation where
I didn't have to kill the zombies like
you can't not kill the zombies in a Z
shaped map it's too dangerous
hey huh what do you mean Z shaped man
you know where it's like just like a
like a Tetris piece what's that piece
called I mean I think it's called the Z
shape I'm so glad I'm so much more
patient nowadays I don't know if you are
I'm a patient as the word I would use
this is kind of it I'm more patient than
I used to be yeah a long time can evil
people will know that are like we
actually there were nights during
resonable
Resident Evil 5 that we like did not
want to talk show ended remember when
you got really stubborn and put down
your controller and didn't fight the
boss of me yes
oh are you [ __ ] kidding me awesome
thank you specially the naked with that
baby hell yeah it's an old painting
depicting a naked baby being held by a
young and old woman was the most obvious
caption I've ever heard and drink coffee
sorry this is the Mona Lisa not that one
sorry hold on this one it totally is
wait go back to the other camera angle
could you see it all of them depict
women that's what it said
there on the left really it's not but it
does definitely look like it I did not
get to see it in Paris I've heard it's
underwhelming did you so you didn't go
to Lube no apparently it's like a de
thing if you want to go we walked by
delight it's massive
like I think of the pyramid which is
apparently its sensitive subject I don't
know I guess like
correct me wrong I know we have viewers
from France but I'm an uncultured swine
so educate know so from what I heard
from what one of our taxi drivers is
telling us if you're like you're from
Paris if you like the pyramid from the
Louvre then you are you are just you're
not respecting traditional French
architecture but if you don't like it
then you are an old like out-of-touch
it's one of those like you can't like it
or not like it I might have explained
that poorly but apparently that's but no
monitor it's not that big or like the
size of that Star Trek thing they can't
see that yeah you can the Star Trek
thing over Mary's shoulder apparently
take that size old mand is holding a
candle in his hand this light will guide
you to a greater truth oh that's cool I
thought it looks important oh that's the
thing for the podium so I can eat this
thingy and then bury it you just drop it
you think I should sharp it yeah you're
fine or you drop drop reload you okay Oh
actually no I got it yeah I could reload
my shot no go back go back go back go
back back out I want to show you some
come on if you aim and the press circle
you can man just reload manually I don't
know if that was in the original
GameCube version it might have been it
might not have been but um marry you
idiot glad you said it all right so it
still doesn't do anything but I could
drop I could drop these three shells I
was like it's not that you want to drop
those not the handgun I don't know I
don't think these things do okay so
those will be marked on the map so
you're good yeah and I think this is for
that podium remember it said uh it's
microfilm inspect it maybe you'll say
something else okay cuz what did you
need for the podium it's a like service
card or something a card insert this
film into a projector to view its
contents
I mean maybe we can try it but I think
that other one was a computer room looks
like a project oh look at this Oh Oh
Billy Billy has a lighter I can switch
and become him this place looks fairly
safe what do you think yeah yeah and
then on the way back you could just have
both bring both of them have him follow
you
oh what's that I don't know
oh god I'm actually did I almost fall in
there can I fall in oh I said I was a
hole
oh I'm assuming you need Billy in here
for one person to turn it the other one
will be on the oh okay I'm gonna bring
him in yeah I like the heartbeat noise
it's nice touch
it's nice all right I think I have
everything I knew a hell on what what is
what's his inventory I'm looking like
it's fairly full but once I use a
shotgun shell then I'm gonna open up a
slot okay I was thinking if you want me
to bring mall togs this is maybe a time
depending on you don't what happens at
the end of this thing so one of those
dudes popped up in the bathroom I think
those things you want to use molotovs on
so yeah say bring it yes bring it
well yeah well your inventory we fold
out yes but I can drop it later okay
okay hey that's statue do you think
that's something that goes in the little
way thing oh yeah maybe he's the evil
thing that you're supposed maybe yeah
yeah he's gonna [ __ ] wake up I know
it and I hate it I know it's like in the
middle of the room like what's this
thing doing there
it's got rubbles bathroom oh this
hallway sucks everything about this game
is stressful I like this game more than
Veronica so far hey someone remember all
the way you really like Veronica I like
Veronica I think this game is nice I
don't know how I feel about going back
and forth between players because I like
the aha moment in puzzles right where
you're like oh I need to do this but
what I don't like is having the aha
moment and then spending 10 minutes
executing it and when you have two
players sometimes it's that right like
you're you already know what you were
supposed to do but you have to spend the
next five minutes doing it and balancing
two players
it's what the [ __ ] was that
it's fun like trying to figure out the
solution it's not fun figuring out and
then having to work even harder
exactly exactly I don't like executing
OHA's I like having a Hoss in the game's
defense I think we could be say this was
like our third playthrough of the game
we would probably know how to avoid
those situations but first time through
yeah I got a little lost here yeah
killing it whatever room you're about to
go into with the lighter looks like it's
it's a dead end so they're probably
something important maybe it's the other
statue maybe it could also be like a bad
guy he could pick up the shotgun shells
so you have them and you have to worry
about I think it's a different shotgun
or is it a shotgun it's a man although
oh it is okay there's so much I don't
know about ammo okay this isn't your
fire to gun we've talked about this
heavily I forgotten yeah this way okay
all right so I want to use only lighter
okay there was no reason to bring Billy
hey why that didn't work no it did not
I think I need to light a candle and
then I light it with a candle hold on
okay I can try again maybe just don't go
into your inventory just click on the
can't thing
are you sure okay I know I know you
would think of this but maybe that's
there's glass around it or something
that seems very contrived well I mean I
don't doubt that you're doing it right
it's just that's annoying it doesn't
sound like you're questioning it
I am you're really sucks is like I can't
get my knife so I have to like shoot
everyone and I can't conserve energy or
like ammo when I like have to shoot
everything if I had a knife I would use
it there's probably a can a little bit
I'm looking for a candle ooh that is a
candle right this thing yeah is it is
flickering a bit
Oh maybe can Rebecca climate oh no it's
not even gay
I'm confused alright we're looking for a
candle we'll do the elevator know should
he do it no no that Billy go up oh why
it's just safe down here and he's got
more health if he goes up and there are
I mean you gotta put him on it first
before you oh you don't even have a bell
um this was a bit of a wash I honestly
think I also went into every [ __ ]
section no I mean well you saw you have
that statue I have the statue I'm gonna
just look stuff up in the interest of it
in case we get super stuck sure I'm
gonna look at the map and see if there's
anything I haven't been I haven't gone
into yet so you can't get at all into
that West Wing it doesn't look like all
the doors are locked
Oh front front lobby there's an unlock
door there you didn't go through yet
bottom-left oh yeah
okay I'll do that right now that's no I
did didn't I
it's that second floor no you went you
went through the second floor door you
didn't go through the I mean I hid
apparently you didn't oh yeah I guess so
this is the second floor or right yeah
okay yeah okay yeah okay Maps
don't follow me I'm just kidding follow
me
[Music]
we're supposed to go
[Music]
let the Phil Collins song for a little
bit yeah take their right
go in here oh you also have that key
card that we didn't try to use yet it's
not a key card
but it's of microfilm and I don't know
read that school over in the classroom
right
it makes there's something I know but
first things first
here crows regular meetings of the
vaccine research and infectious agents
teams will be held both meetings are
security level five and will be held in
the following locations operation
control room southeast meeting room
entry code is 8:15 from what room I
don't think we got in there yet no I
don't think a candle I hope Oh crank
yeah it's weird
square crank this room is very close to
the lobby so you could drop anything
pretty much
you think this room's safe though no no
well I hear the crows
I hear the crows - this whole room seems
scary I don't like it maybe drop some
things does Billy have stuff yeah it's
really full they're both full time I eat
this thingy I won't be on caution no
more or do you think that's not worth it
I'd say wait for a read let's drop it I
think you're fine dropping stuff in here
if that's what you were asking yeah
that's why I like item boxes cuz they're
like I can just have them okay so now we
know we're good to go now elevator
[Music]
I didn't totally look in that room yet
either
I think you got everything
all right so I'm seeing tips that say
once you get the shock on the e hunting
gun is more of a burden and it's just
taking up space you might as well devote
all the shotgun shells to your shotgun
oh that's good to know
all right well I will um there's gotta
be a projector in here judging by my
knowledge of projectors it might be at
the back of the room oh you big dumb
idiot merry I hate
okay I can't all right well he's got two
in there so I think the thing is like I
don't want him using anymore so I'm
gonna drop my shells here that way I
don't accidentally use any more than I
want to
does that make sense yeah and then I
need to go to this room it's yeah it's
yeah
oh no you already know yeah yeah yes you
big idiot so easy get lost in here okay
just called me an idiot I can get lost
and you can still be an idiot they're
not mutually exclusive I'm getting a
work thing on acceptin you used to pull
up the map oh I still pull it up as much
I think you're just this is like the
patient thing like you've like let that
go I know I told you a more patient do
you goddamn [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] give me
the winch winch okay it is settled a
plane spider-man I only you're allowed
to talk about it
we can say we have it that we've been
playing I just can't talk about the game
specifically that's cool yeah I saw some
spider-man looking games on your TVs but
I didn't say anything because I didn't
want to be that person you probably see
way more than you should when you're
here obviously scoff at that though hey
[ __ ] get on it so he said oh wait I did
the opposite ie this is so fun look at
my bit is this an appropriate outfit for
a lift
can you see I've made my dukes Duke can
I make him lower it oh that didn't get
me that wasn't that was an act I'm just
putting on a play you touch his body
yeah let me watch you touch it
what's going on up here what it's all
these machines Oh what's on the wall
what's up with all these machines Oh
8:59 damn it
Oh son of a [ __ ] oh the way that thing
moved
wait you're missing it where did you
drop the shotgun shells where's Billy
still have them drop them
yeah you know I'm wow I
what a terrible camera angle thank you I
thought you're gonna say something about
yank you me but definitely I'll be nice
it's definitely I'm mr. Page definitely
not me that's what we call you at work
there's mr. patient there is mr. patient
struttin by then [ __ ] really calm
demeanor side no well I made it handy
outside yeah I guess so why would a lot
of things the edge old question I'm
running out of bullets don't make that
noise if I'm not allowed to eat you're
not allowed to make that noise ever
Excel to be alien for McCain signs do
you think that bird [ __ ] no wait walk
slowly
or you have your light oh you're not
Billy
or have your light ya member your
lighter the lighter guitar crowd do you
think okay if you just walk and don't
sprint then it doesn't have a walk
button yes tank controls did you use the
pad okay I think
these are my sneakin dude Shh
most most women wear daisies but I'm
more of a sneaky Dukes kind of girl oh
it didn't work
oh you're attacking my scalp meri you're
hurt that's like the staircase woman who
died al killed her they're gonna kill me
what should I do
I'd shoot them this is concerning oh no
I don't want to go check them out
like what is out here that I need whoa
what's that
you should run toward the door well
there's a there's a leaf cut off right
there's enough there's a red one too I
believe where I don't know what those
crows to get you anyway I think it's
that little element it goes straight and
then I want to go left the redder might
be right next to you
see me Juke that shitty ass bird mm-hmm
Juke that crow oh he got me
he's crowing me Juke and crows that's a
[ __ ] oh wait I can't [ __ ] take this
[ __ ] I'm on red caution you [ __ ]
well at least it's marked on your map
now well how about this I just don't
believe Rebecca I could drop something
I'm micro cut the herb in them right
yeah cuz I'm gonna make it what this
crows are gonna make it complicated that
I got it
complicated for a scrub but not for me
oh oh wait you could've just okay
no I sweet [ __ ] hate crows you fight
like a crow you fight like what you
can't set it up like that for me most
psychopathic noise I've ever heard you
make mmm that's crew that's what crews
me I know what a crow makes you want
here than what's annoying someone well
mom no it's a raven on my arm they're
not that different
wait do you combine the herbs yes kinky
oh that doesn't look good that doesn't
don't [ __ ] this puzzle up look scary
room let's check them out okay I can't
go anywhere yeah you can't there's
stairs I said I can't go anywhere
[Music]
are these the stairs yes
little concerning I'm gonna go down here
these are my stair dukes stop not
everything is Duke related oh [ __ ]
that's for bathroom with the [ __ ]
thing no it's the short no it's not it's
oh but it's a shirt
no pink it is a shortcut to the to the
foyer a are you sure no but it's a
shortcut give a shotgun still yeah you
have one shell though yeah I say dodge
it because it's gonna take two shells to
kill that thing
what do you mean dodge it [ __ ] Juke
that [ __ ] I can't Juke a bug Juke and
Bob's hell yeah you can't I've seen you
do it I'm confused
I believe in you wait did you heal yet
no yeah cuz I'm only on orange that's
close to red though I know that's like
one color away I know listen I don't
want to die any more than anyone else I
would prefer not to use the herb I'd say
and then just you get because I don't
you can't kill it I mean you could you
can kill you shoot it once the shotgun
shell and then take your pistol out but
I don't think you can kill it with one
shotgun shell so you can either do you
think if it hits me it will kill me
because there's me and it puts me on red
then I have herbs and then I don't waste
ur okay yeah you can just try to do get
now without healing but if it kills me
then it's not good it's your fault
the blood is off my hands
I'm gonna do it just insane myself from
this whole sure got it I got it I got it
I got it I got it I got it I got it I
got it I'm not ready for - what should I
do
first of all I need to eat these orbs
yeah sure and then just you go I can't
you - I don't you can't kill to him you
definitely can't kill - I can't I have
bullets you have I think that's too many
bullets to use should I just turn around
and run you need those other shotguns
show I can do that I can go get them
they're not that far so you're
definitely if this is a shortcuts a lot
of you're gonna use as Billy so it might
be worth killing them okay yeah wait
we're the shotgun shells with Billy
they're with Billy I stay okay I still
think you should you through unlock it
go into the lobby meet up with Billy
again get the shells from him no just
turn around and meet up with Billy I
don't have to go through such a long
longer path in this this path has two
bugs in front of it yeah I know but it's
it's a worthwhile shortcut am i eating
these things or not no no no just you
just try to dodge I'm just [ __ ] move
like wait
is that not right wait what remember
even now I thought I was in this room no
no your read your oh right I've been
looking at this guy for real wait go
back go back you don't need to be in
here I don't need to be there's another
door weird weird unlocking the wrong
door I know I've been looking at all
right let's go unlocked a lobby or and
bring Billy into this I actually don't
even think a crow could scratch me right
now no no go no go no go to the end of
this hallway that's where the door is to
the lobby it is yeah that's what I
thought we were looking at that's red I
know you can unlock it from this side
how do you know it's just it why else
would it be there it can't be locked
from both sides there you go right now
you couldn't bring Billy back into the
mix okay so wait won't you need him for
that Billy to come here yeah you should
probably kill those bugs it looks like
an intersection this is a safe area
right help okay well he can't
all right you couldn't have even got him
you can only send one person up at a
time now this allows both render god
that makes way where didn't you leave
the shotgun shells in here I did wait I
left them in this room you left him
upstairs didn't you
no oh there's a guy there don't move
Billy idiot it's in is it in this room
wait you can you can look on the map
press X you go to the shotgun you're
yeah you're right they're in a classroom
it's a blue one yeah okay so I gotta
kill this thing now nah she's not even
looking at you just Juke him well I
think he's in my way you're on green and
you could take a beating you're Billy I
don't want to take a beating you don't
have to just Jim
it's a hallway go closer I'm an assess
the situation from them actually it's a
circle so as long as yeah he's facing
the corner you can get around him
he's gonna turn around and hit me just
do it it's bad advice that was but you
didn't you don't take my spill come from
okay I'm gonna get these shotgun shells
from a girl now I think I'm full I'm
pretty sure oops I didn't mean to do
that
that's alright I'm just gonna check on
her she's good she good she good all
right and then you or no you have a spot
all right so you're gonna pick these up
pick them up Billy big idiot and then
this is outside right
ya know that's the lobby that's the lot
where she is I think about outside the
mansion
this is believing and Trini was beating
the game pen off me
hey girl alright so we going back in
here where she came from right you could
give her the shotgun shells to kill his
bugs she's almost dead or he could take
the shotgun rights
I think I'd like him to do it because
she's so in G you know you might as well
use the last two shells from that
hunting gun well that's inconvenient
no not now I just meant at some point
okay oops
give me a manual
so she's gonna follow me and I don't
want her going in that room because I
don't want her getting hurt - is that
the right way to do this yeah
should I throw Molotov on them no save
those for those regenerator guys are you
sure that's what some people said in the
comments okay I trust them okay so I'm
gonna shock on them but I only have four
shotguns that's enough okay and I get
down and I don't want her coming though
right and you should aim down okay come
on
is that a flamethrower oh nice you got
about a grenade launcher it looks like
the other one took whoo shotgun shells
the net gain is another statute yes is
it yes is that the good and evil is that
the good to the other ones evil maybe
okay so let's talk about this cuz I
think we're both full and where are we
can I get through here or is this a dead
end the Sedona
unless I check the door oh there's a
fire motif ice-water
the gaseous version of ice yeah
all right so I have not a lot of empty
spots but I wish I could take shells out
of that shotgun
I like regret loading that shotgun a lot
which one the shitty one like I said
just use those two shells you don't
waste them and keep mine you can get
this stuff whenever you want well I'd
say I'd say a lot of it now the grenade
launcher I don't think you need right
now but I'd say get the if that's the
stick is that good or bad
good some dude examine it clearly what
are you doing I've got I've got a visual
aid now sad she's got a nice touch see
what are you doing just examining
anybody Billy right yeah you know we're
in danger right yeah
where's that bathroom yeah I don't know
there's a monster in there though it's
fine I don't care he's gonna go call my
mom but they've made him this character
it's not my fault was that noise
that looks like stop wait what'd it say
it said this grandfather clock is broken
broken stopped ticking all together was
there a minute Hannah here something I
was thinking about that but I didn't see
one all right so we're coming up on an
hour-ish before we can watch the video I
did not forget we need to we got the lay
of the land I think this is more
productive than you thought well I mean
I was in a lot of rooms today yeah and I
have a statue both you could do that all
right what's going on up here let me
know no that seems dangerous right all
right so we're going back is that what's
happening how do I go back down the
stairs I forgot about the thing all
right so we're just gonna go back to the
main lobby I got a statue do you want to
put the statue on the thingy you could
put both sides on and we'll call it at
that see what happens we gotta watch the
intro video okay
I just know make sure she doesn't die
that's important to me
you could go do it with oh yeah she's on
low health you leave stuff in here and
go because the other statues on the
floor down here I love that they're a
version of good in good versus evil is
just
like like our super sexualized statue
yeah
statue little mater war yeah statue the
alluring glow of Electric sex oh it's
right up here second when boobs and ass
you know what we never examined this one
I can't imagine why we did it but I oh
my god
check out that 4-pack he's rocking yeah
there might be some underneath that
chain oh yeah something else under there
too oh man nice he could chain me up
thanks check out the cakes on that check
out the [ __ ] flower bags on this dude
that guy's got some nice dodge balls he
must work out he's got some four square
chalk
check out the Samsung monitors on that
okay no one I've never heard that one no
yeah
okay so they're not balanced oh you have
to like [ __ ] find like an arm I have
to find like a third boobie or no no no
maybe you have to rip off can you break
off the wing or reverse hammer
there's a small hole in the back yeah
also very small when the demons balloon
not is open ah not allowed to say
balloon ah where you started that one
yeah says there's a hole
that's like where it's other wing used
to go yeah okay was it for later yeah
probably
you could still leave them there just so
you know where they are which is good
yeah that sucks though because it
doesn't really believe she got hurt
again I'm having a real bad it's a good
smile say we don't have health plan I
think there's something coming up that
we could start a next episode with so I
only have one ink rib well you got you
had those are the ones near the the lot
though is it you'll find more you've
only found like one type two typewriters
in the mansion so far training facility
whatever it's called Billy okay I'll do
that intro video okay
so just quit out and start a new wash it
with that overwrite the no I don't think
so
uh I feel about that
no there's multiple save it won't quit
game yeah new or no two op extras maybe
it's just an extras okay opening
this is nice
a Midwestern town a Midwestern in
America now I'm an acute city a solitary
island roquefort island an island that
would become the second Raccoon City
Sheena Island place from there are still
many unanswered questions about these
seemingly undulation yet intensely
traumatic events though it is believed
that the international enterprise
umbrella was somehow involved little is
known as to the origin of this faceless
corporation when was it established by
whom and how was the t-virus created
to one cover the truth we must delve
deeper into the events which transpired
in the beginning before the mansion
incident
[Music]
birthday hmm do you think so - yeah
[Music]
this way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pretty good opener
like I was just dancing on a mountain
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
Bravo key number the helicopter simple
investigation of some bizarre murders in
the suburbs of Raccoon City nothing in
our training good boys have prepared us
for the nightmare that in
see forth you never stood a chance
[Music]
engine failure emergency landing
I'm Mikey
first guys name check the current
position and investigate the surrounding
area this reminds me of for captain look
captain what happened court order for
transportation prisoner Billy Coen ex
lieutenant 26 years old court-martialed
and sentenced death July 22nd prisoners
to be transferred to the rageth on base
for execution
those poor soldiers bury no good just
doing their jobs and that scum murdered
them and escaped
Oh Barry let's separate and survey the
area our friend is brutal and ruthless
keep your guard up
yeah this context is really helpful
who dare a train
[Music]
how did the train start
[Music]
good question
wait what's on the next one did we watch
did we miss that one too this is officer
chambers from stars Bravo tree please
identify yourself
is someone there do you remember this
one I think a Brella starts it okay cool
does it provide some immediate context
oh I was gonna say can I like cheat here
but it looks like wait
so people so I know what that missing
one is so if you had picked two Rebecca
to go to the back of the train for the
brakes she would have seen one of those
stars members Billie saman didn't affect
him which is kind of cool because if
there was a Becca she would have like
hesitated and not and not killed a
zombie that would have been that thing
according to comics that's cool so it's
like some lore mm-hmm um really quick
let me good job Nathan Shepard as always
with stats you know it's been a while
when the Scorpion has become the crab
statistics of the playthrough thus far
one death yes one death so far 25 kills
19 times for Cerberus is one mimicry
Marcus and one stinger okay you killed a
few plague I've been shooting on four
times more than that now recoveries four
saves three see you guys again in next
week thank you as always Nathan Shepard
yeah that's good alright well I haven't
died but I've definitely been chewed on
yeah wasn't a great week
I got eaten a couple times but I didn't
die need some exploration yeah and I
think um yeah the map is
I've definitely uncovered a lot more in
the map I'm actually not sure we're
gonna do next week but we have time to
figure that out so we got a lot done
yeah we'll be at PAX but we'll be right
back if you guys are going we well it'll
be Saturday when you guys see this but
if anyone's going to PAX West Mike and I
are both going so stop by and say hi to
Knievel peeps and we'll be on a kind of
funnies inter website tournament
Saturday 7:00 Pacific if you want to
watch that
oh yeah the funnies channel and stuff
working Mary and Dan Reicher working in
tandem working together against each
other together we're facing off in the
first bracket facing off together yes
okay anyway thanks everybody have a good
rest of the weekend as always and we'll
see you next week
[Music]